the joe rogan experience when are you
moving to texas uh the end of the month
whoa yeah i'm out of here this place is
crazy
this place is going to sink watch as
soon as i leave
boom i just thought it's it's [ __ ]
this place is crazy
the the the lockdown still exists right
there's
the homelessness is completely out of
control um
there's the overpopulation is out of
control the way they're handling this
is so bad i'm just upset with the
federal government's handling of this
everybody's hand there's so many people
that are just
financially they're so [ __ ] right now
and i think people should be
i don't i mean i don't want to say
people should be held accountable for
but i think people should make decisions
based on the way the place that they
live
is handling this really difficult
problem
and the way the solution they've come up
with in california is to jack up taxes
so the most recent solution was to jack
up taxes to 54 percent
i'm like you guys are out of your
[ __ ] mind
retroactively back to jail there's a
proposal
it's crazy it's not gonna fix it they're
bankrupt this state is bankrupt because
they're incompetent
they're not going to become competent if
you give them more money you know it's
just
they've they've managed the money that
they got very poorly they already have
high taxes
there's a 13.5 state income tax here in
california
and the place is still [ __ ] up it's
like
this is a this is a very telling and
dangerous time
in a lot of ways it's very challenging
and uh it exposes a lot of things and
one of the things that exposes
i don't i don't particularly like the
way things are run here and i
i don't like being in a place that has
such a high population either i think
there's a real problem with living
somewhere that has 20 million people
plus 40 million in the whole state it's
so crazy
there's so many people here and the only
thing that was really keeping me around
was the comedy store and my friends
and a lot of my friends are bailing a
lot i mean there's where are they going
all over the place my friend joey's
moved in new jersey
uh theo vaughn is moving i think he's
moving to nashville
a lot of my friends are talking about
texas people are just bailing there's a
mass exodus out of california right now
that's crazy because i was actually
planning to move to l.a eventually so
now that you're going i was going to say
the next time i'm in town i'll come say
hi but you're going to be gone
well maybe i'll be here every now and
then you know look once things are back
to normal whatever normal is going to be
i'd be happy to come in every now and
then and we're going to keep this studio
for a while i'll come to the comedy
store and
still do shows there i miss all my
friends that that work there and
that perform there so i i'm sure i'll be
in town
at least a few times a year but uh i
just want to change too
you know i think um there's other places
to live i want to live in a place where
it rains
you know that's another thing it's like
it's very unhealthy
living in a place where it's always
sunny i think it gives you a really
delusional perspective
it's beautiful for you because you come
from toronto it's 55
000 degrees below zero well it's not
snowing every day counter to what people
think we do actually have summer and
sunshine sometimes
of course you do look i love toronto but
the the thing is like when people come
from somewhere like that and then you
come to la and it's sunny all the time
you're like this is amazing
but after a while it's like it gives you
a distorted view of nature
you know and i think that's one of the
reasons why people in la are so
delusional
they very rarely have to deal with
actual nature i always felt like there
was something real humbling about
growing up in boston because it got so
goddamn cold and it snowed so much
that you just knew like there were
certain point times where you
had to submit to nature you were you had
a huddle in
there's two feet of snow outside you
just stayed home
you just you know hung out with the
family you played games you did what you
had to do no one's going anywhere the
roads are shut down
they have to plow it takes days and
there's something about that
just understanding that sometimes you
have to be at the beck and call and the
will of nature
that doesn't exist in california every
20 years or so we get a wake-up call the
earth shakes and buildings fall down you
go [ __ ] i gotta get out of here and then
people move out and then a couple years
later they forget a bunch of people move
in
and then it gets overcrowded again but
this is like one of the first
years i think where california didn't
grow
and that's uh that's very strange
because every year california's
population just keeps growing and
growing and growing
and they're saying this this is one of
the very first years in recent memory
where it's not growing
so many people are leaving that it's
actually not growing
change is good
[Applause]
you